when clooney who's a friend of yours
calls you and says i want to uh direct
you in a movie the tender bar do you
feel some obligation that you have to do
it i mean the guy's a great director
he's a great uh you know he's a great
actor first of all i always want to work
with george as an actor because matt
always said the guy's spectacular to
work as an actor
what does that mean why is he
spectacular to work for
well i'll tell you what it was for me
um
imagine working for a guy who's done
your job
at the highest level for longer than you
have right so george his notes are like
just so [ __ ] sharp and you can play
them a lot of directors sit down and
talk about like well you know you're
called you're red and you know this is a
movie about you know uh the motion of in
you're just like i can't i don't know
what to do with that george would go you
know what i like leaning forward wait
till the second line you know or it's
great what you're doing i see that
that's too small bring it up a little
bit at the end and it's just so much
better this movie is almost a parallel
this little boy goes to talk to his
uncle at a bar you used to meet your
father at a bar which is just [ __ ]
crazy and he probably was hammered i
can't even imagine the bitterness and
what you missed out on in life
i think that the thing about this movie
is because i've seen both the sides of
the father i understand how [ __ ]
important fathers are
uh you know in the sense and then have
to be you know i'm talking about men and
women okay you can be two two moms two
dads none but whatever your family
system is whatever it looks like
what matters is
that
the you
show the children with your time and
attention that you believe in them and
that they have worth
and that they can do hard things
and they love them
and the way that you do that which i
think is really interesting in this
movie is you know the uncle charlie's
the exaggerated version where he's like
you're no good at sports don't take up
sports you suck you know but i love you
and you can do this then the kid goes
okay
i can do it you wanna hug that kid i
mean uh it was so easy i mean my son was
nine he was nine i was you know i was
like i felt right i fell in love with
the kid this is the thing when being a
celebrity man most of the time i'm like
famous [ __ ] i hate it
but then there's times where like you
know he's doing the junk with me last
night i said what do you want for
christmas you know and he he's like i
want you know basketball jerseys i like
basketball does he like basketball he's
like yeah you know i like uh you know i
like the knicks and i like you know i'm
giving him [ __ ] about the necks and i
said yeah yeah well you like to go to
basketball today never been
there's never been a basketball game
right then i was like okay this is going
to come in handy because you know i do
know people it's like okay who's playing
tonight they get some [ __ ] floor
seats daniel's gonna go basketball game
with his mom and dad and it's like you
know he was out there i didn't you know
watching this
you know i mean he's adorable i was
going to give that oh give something
help somebody give something nice for
somebody there's no more joyful thing
than that
you